Je suis honnête avec vous
, chaque personne a sa propre
idée personnelle de qui Moïse devrait être
l'année de votre naissance, il y avait une
prophétie selon laquelle notre chef serait né
pour libérer les esclaves sur lesquels nous voulions nous
concentrer sur la relation entre
Moïse  et les hommes de Ramsès qui ont grandi en tant que
frères qui ont grandi en tant que princes les
esclaves vous devez mettre en place un cadre et cela
crée une grande bataille dynamique entre
quelque chose arrive alors c'est hors de mon
contrôle
Moïse croit que sa place en tant que chef de la
révolution
dans la libération des esclaves et  puis retournant
au pays de leurs ancêtres dire nous
périrons
suivez-moi et vous serez libre
il s'assure que ces gens
vont gagner leur liberté
toi
je joue ramsès ii ramsès est très proche
quoique dans une relation compétitive
avec Moïse quand je  regarde toi je
vois toujours les deux garçons qui ont grandi ensemble
près des frères
Moses Ames à Ramses est le plus
préféré des deux garçons par son propre
père je te fais plus confiance que lui supprimer
et traverser  h le cours de l'histoire
devient le pur opposé à un ami
il y a une explosion dramatique entre
deux personnages
les esclaves vous devez un laps de temps ce n'est
pas une menace
oui c'est le fondement de tout le
futur conflit
voyons juste qui est le plus efficace pour
tuer  toi moi et puis va fondamentalement
en guerre avec Moïse et ses idéaux je suis un
dieu l'histoire est grande je veux dire massive
toi